what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed we're going shopping
with sophia and sistine stallone
we just become best friends yep
[Music]
happy tuesday happy tuesday everyone
welcome back to another episode
of the unwaxed podcast i am sistine and
i'm sophia and as i always say if it's
your first time welcome
if you're back good good yeah
i feel like you know how ellen has her
thing what's her thing she always says
at the end be kind to be kind
of should that be my thing uh
oh we could work on it we'll work on the
work well think about it as i say with
every episode i feel like we have lots
to catch up on it's been a
productive somewhat busy week yeah
would you like to go ahead and oh
actually can i start yeah go ahead
um so i know i've trashed uh tick tock
on this podcast before right because
not because i think the app is bad or
the people on the app is bad but simply
because
i am bitter that my tick tocks get no
likes
and i think i make quality funny tick
tock and you actually do i think you put
in a lot of effort
and they only need to be seen a thousand
views
barely but the biggest ones on tick tock
are the ones
with me because that's not the point i'm
not even not that big with sophia
but no offense they're the biggest ones
but
sophia and i decided the other day let's
make a tick tock
uh nobody asked for it but i think it
would be fun and
but we've had an obsession with the show
new girl yes
and so we were thinking oh what do we do
and we're like oh schmidt
like let's do some voice over dialogue
from the show yeah
so we did this tick tock we posted it
literally not thinking anything no we
come back from dinner
and i go sophia check your phone right
now and she goes what i'm like
i'm not kidding in one day we got five
hundred thousand views
on this one it blew up and she gained i
don't know how many followers you gained
thousands of followers thousands of
followers and i still don't even think
it's that good of a tick tock
i think it was pretty good but it's i
think we figured out the algorithm
because everyone kept saying i want to
go that deep no i want to say because
people writing
i want to stay on schmidt talk or like
new girl talk because you know when you
watch something and then it appears all
the time on your feed
yes i think we were on like everyone's
new girl tick tock page
i agree and i think we well at least for
me my ego is a little bit uh
puffed up right now i'm just gonna ride
this wave
of having a one-hit wonder tick tock for
as long as no
we're gonna figure this out but anyway
um i'm back on the tick tock love train
speaking of love train third date
last week yes i went on a second date
ended up being successful therefore we
went on a third date
and i say that the third date is the
most
crucial date i'm sorry sophia you said
that about the second date
you literally said that last night okay
i changed my mind the second date
it's both of those are like getting to
know now you know each other
now it's when it's you're comfortable
you probably have an inside joke
we got a few you got a few inside jokes
they're a little bit more loosey-goosey
so now
it shows if you guys actually have like
real chemistry
i agree with that but i'm still trying
to be very i guess i'm not trying to one
of the things that guys always say about
sophia and i is that we're extremely
hard to read
and they can't figure us out and i'm
like good i want to be a puzzle that you
can
never put together well because i feel
like we internalize
everything and we'll show how we we are
we're very expressive people but i think
that whenever it comes to actually
saying some to someone we like them or
showing we like them
we think we are but we're actually not i
feel like our things are like
oh we'll touch you or we'll like play
around with you but then
they're like thinking that's just your
personality that doesn't mean you like
them
i don't know that's kind of how i we we
unintentionally
play games yeah we play a little
hard to get is that bad whatever
whatever
whatever whatever but um anything you
would like to share about your love life
sophia
um yeah winkling okay
i'm a little i'm a little um it's a
little rough morning
for sophia she's a little hungover she
didn't take the cbd talk spells
that's probably the problem but um i
saw someone i used to go out with last
night
just somebody that i used to know
yeah so uh everyone says you shouldn't
go
hang out with an ex or talk to an ex but
i
i'm gonna stop you right there only you
say that
because you judge me for yes sophia i
keep a friendship with all of my actors
because your exes are not nice people
i don't like that makes no sense yeah it
does i mean if i
i just like to be on good terms with my
exes you look at an ex like
cut them off because it's easier to move
on yeah whereas i like to
put myself through an emotional torture
chamber
yeah by staying in contact but you
decided to reach out
reached out he was in town and i won't
get into like the little details but i
was
having this whole talk with sistine and
a lot of my friends about
how do you know whether it's real
feelings again like new
or if it's nostalgia especially when it
was someone you used to go out with
because you have the comfortability
level already there you guys know each
other
literally inside and out and it's always
hard to because you knew this person
when
you were much younger yeah and you guys
are in your mid-20s and you're at
different places in your life so the
relationship will never
be what it once was right no it's going
to be totally different but
you have to figure out whether or not
those things if you do feel anything
if it's just a comfortability level or
if it's real
so you're testing yourself will your
love stand
the test of time i sound like a talk
show it sounds like the worst talk show
or no no deal yeah are you opening the
briefcase are you walking away
no no we're not doing this right now no
no i have zero answer for this i just
wanted to say that and i'm leaving it
that i'm more excited for your date
because it's new it's fragile it's
exciting
it is really exciting oh what else is
exciting
this is my favorite month of the year
why is it sistine
you guys i am a halloween fanatic
insanely obsessed with halloween yeah no
i'm the type that'll make
at least i don't make them but i
actually do put them together four
costumes maybe five for no one like i'll
literally buy
and do an entire full face of makeup
just for being around the house she'll
do it yeah in general she'll put
uh she'll make herself into a deer one
day with a bullet
so i'll be like yeah it's just really
weird like in the middle of september
like last year i got
a bunch of prosthetics for sophia and i
always think it's fun to dress up with
someone
and so i dressed up as an old fisherman
with one missing arm maybe it's the
ghost fisherman if you listen to the
other episode it's probably that
it is probably so i was an old fisherman
with one missing arm a scar
all over my face and sophia i was mr
monopoly
it looked like a penguin yes but you
have to understand the storyline you
know she was the captain
i i owned the yacht yes exactly i was
like the rich
monopoly man with the yacht and then
sistine was
the old sailor men we don't really know
we don't know it's still we're still
we're still trying but i think the most
fun thing we do every halloween is that
we have a tradition where we
dress up in the way we want to dress up
like maybe cute sexy i don't know
and then cece and i always go all out
and something really weird and stupid
and funny
so this was my idea for this year and
sophia and we're getting scarlet
involved too
they have they don't want to be a part i
don't want to do this one
but i think it's so funny i was thinking
we all dress up as the blue men group no
so we get bald caps paint our entire
body's blue that's what i don't want to
do that is so
much working blue is going to be
everywhere
so it's gonna be funny but we're not
leaving the house
it's quarantined we're gonna be running
around the house in full-blown blue
paint
no what if we went to dinner that's the
blue mangrove
it would be so should we bring drums you
guys that is the point of halloween to
me to do something that is completely
transformative and you don't look like
yourself and i sometimes love just doing
the opposite of the stereotypical
sexy witch or sexy well it keeps it
interesting yeah
yeah okay so we are super excited to
have on travis mills
and we hope you enjoy it cysteine as you
know
i've had horrible teeth growing up i've
always had
that's true yeah they're always uneven
my bottom teeth are still uneven and
they were never straight and that was a
huge insecurity of mine
but now someone came up to us and told
us about this amazing company that
actually can
accomplish that for you way quicker way
easier
thanks to candid straightening your
teeth is simpler easier and
more comfortable than ever yeah again
they're removable they're comfortable
and they're
practically invisible unlike the gross
wire braces that you and i
unfortunately had to deal with for years
they will literally transform your teeth
and no one will notice it's all done at
home so you don't have to worry about
people coming over it's like comfortable
it's at the convenience store
right now there's a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in teeth
movement who remote
who monitors you and like prescribes you
everything which is if you need the
supervising they're going to be with you
every single step of the way and you
won't even believe
how quick the treatments you actually
are it's six months six months
six months you'll start seeing results
so quick and it costs
thousands guys thousands less than
braces
okay so i know we've talked it up you're
gonna go get it right now so let me show
you how to do that
start straightening your teeth today
right now all of our listeners can save
75
on candid starter kit go to candid co
dot com slash unwaxed and use code
unwaxed
that's candid c o dot com slash unwaxed
code
unwaxed take advantage of this limited
time offer to save
seventy five dollars on your starter kit
candid
co.com unwaxed code unwaxed
cysteine guess what what i'm hungover
yep i drank way too much tequila typical
guess what i didn't do
cbd talks you probably have it in your
room and
being me and being my age we get hung
over very easily you get headaches you
get
brain fog you get it's like impossible
to get out of bed in the morning and so
we found
when this company came out to us that it
changes your life
yeah it's let me break it down it's a
cbd
based hangover remedy that targets the
physical and mental aspects of a
hangover
it's a natural compound found in hemp
that can help you feel calmer
alleviate pain nausea and help your body
get rid of toxins so had
sophia done this yesterday she would be
feeling like a spring chicken this
morning and also remember just because
it's cbd doesn't mean it has thc it has
zero percent thc
so it won't make you high people so you
wake up feeling refreshed
energized and ready to start your day
it's super easy
all you have to do is take one dose
before you go to bed and the next
morning if you need it
and i'm telling you it really works
so we have a special 20 off discount for
you
go to shop.getcbdtalks.com
shop.getcbdtalks that is
c b d t o tox.com and use the code on
wax at checkout
they offer a 30-day money-back guarantee
so you have nothing to lose when trying
it out
again go to shop.getcbdtalks.com
and use the code on wax for 20 off you
can also find them on instagram at
cbd talks remedy let us know what you
think because we definitely love it
all right we have an extremely talented
individual with us are you ready for
this intro
are you ready bring it it's pretty good
i'm going to blush oh i'm going to make
you so
red so firstly you may know him as his
stage name
t mills old stage name i'll stay scary
she told me she's r.i.p rest in peace
and there were about seven stage names i
didn't know which one i kind of closed
my eyes i picked one all right
you are an actor host of mtv's ghosted
and the request show on beats one in
addition
he has his own podcast called adhd a
youtube channel and as if his plate
wasn't full enough he is continuing his
long music career
with the release of his new album called
girlfriends we have
travis in the building wow what an
introduction
this has been such a long time coming
we've been wanting to meet you for a
while i've been wanting to meet you all
yeah we love like following you and
seeing the things you're doing yeah
i'm a fan of you so yeah
well congratulations for the podcast
thank you no but we're here to gas you
up stop casting okay yeah come on
i can't get we can't do this together no
no no we got each other together
but i'm so excited i really want to dive
into your new album
girlfriends which you can get october
23rd october 23rd yeah
so exciting so like tell me about the
name how did you come up with
the idea for girlfriends yeah so the
band is called girlfriends
so it's nick and i um and look i took
like a three or four year hiatus from
making music
and i was still making music but i was
writing songs for other people um and i
just wasn't releasing anything
in december of last year uh i called
nick
because nick and i had been friends for
like six years right i was like yo i
want to do something again
and he was like okay and i was like but
i wanted to be completely different from
like all my solo music
uh and he was like yeah so we started
getting in the studio and then
january like i got the flu really bad it
wasn't coveted
yeah does it say was it like it wasn't
coke
i took the whole like uh antibody test
yeah whatever i didn't have
them i was hoping that i did because
i've been saying i want
and i don't want kobe but like i want to
knock on wood
he's like i don't want to come in the
studio anymore
no but just to say i have the antibodies
yes but so i was hoping for it i didn't
but anyway so nick and i
i got the flu i got i got better i went
and met up with nick we like got in the
studio for a day then nick got the flu
also wasn't covered oh wow this isn't
like is that your fault
no no completely unrelated um a very
healthy start to this
girlfriend yeah it took like a month for
us to like recover
just so we could like work together and
then we were in the studio for like
three weeks and then everything shut
down
which yeah was kind of a blessing like
for
the music right it sucks for the entire
world and for everyone going through
this totally
but we got to like lock out in a studio
for three months and like not do
anything but like focus that's really
nice you guys kind of just like hunkered
down and just like
isolated don't they say the boredom is
like the best time
to have even like the most creativity
just because when you're having nothing
to do
you have to think of things to do and so
all of a sudden all these things start
coming up and
did you have the songs already ready to
go like did you write things before
i i mean i'm always writing like i have
a notes app on my iphone that i abuse
oh so do we we have like dog names we
have everything
you write a list of dog names hold up
yeah for dogs
are probably probably way more
intelligent they were cool and beautiful
i'm like
pancake syrup like what do we need what
do we need from the grocery store i like
to work out for the day i just write
like anything and
and everything um and it's just a bunch
of rambling so i'll just take that into
the studio and like write songs so i
feel like i'm okay i'm always like
writing
and then i'm also really creative at
like four in the morning because like
i'm an insomniac
really wait you're a night owl oh yeah
i'm so obsessed we're in bed by 9 30.
9 30 9 30 bed wake up hold on i've been
taking a lot of melatonin so that's been
helping
i read a lot of books see i can't do
that i start hallucinating we'll talk
after i got some good stuff okay
okay i can wake up early though too i'm
like both
so like i could like i could like go to
sleep at three and like wake up at seven
and totally you're fine
yeah i'm good and i don't take naps i
don't take i
can't nap yeah i wake up depressed like
if i take a nap and it's like three or
four
pm and then i wake up and like the sun's
going down i'm like in the worst mood
and i'm like what day is it
that's how we feel it completely ruins
your day 100
um i want to talk about your songs that
you've already released california
which already has a million streams by
the way over a million streams that's
insane
and eyes wide shut which is a sick name
by the way thank you
both of which how many times what did i
listen to
so many times to the point where my mom
was like enough it was so your mom hates
my music
yes jennifer loves music now
it's not mom music no it was so much fun
to listen to
yeah it really is how has the response
been since you've dropped those songs
it's been incredible like i i've kind of
fallen in love with the process all over
again like it reminds me of like when i
first started my solo project and like
yeah
building everything and it's like super
organic but also i was
it's so hard to like release music
during a pandemic and that was a big
thing that we talked about like yo is
this the right time it felt like super
self-centered and like egotistical to be
like hey here's my new band
right you know i mean i agree but i also
have to disagree because this
is your craft like again i've been
stalking you and you've been
you know tr doing music since you're
five years old yeah
so it's it's it comes out of your pores
you know constantly exercise and work
that muscle in your brain
for music i mean i don't think it's a
bad thing yeah and it was a conversation
like yo we don't know when this is going
to end
right so it's like what am i just going
to like stop like you you aren't
stopping doing podcasts
well last thing we were on pause for so
long we're like this is not going to
come up anytime soon it's
people are going to probably want to
listen to it even more since they're
going to be in their cars they're going
to be at home
and so now we got new music it's like
it's just great yeah 100
um and so yeah it's been it's been
really fun and you know the whole album
i mean in my opinion it's like i know
everyone this is so
stupid because everyone's like oh it's
the best stuff we've ever done no it's
but
no but it really does feel like that do
you have any
people that are coming on like special
guests like features
yeah yeah i have a guest can i guess
okay i think mgk is coming on
no he's not on the album he's not on the
album
but it it there is a possibility of us
doing something very soon we've been
friend we've been mean closely been
friends for like 10 years oh that's
she just worked with him on set actually
oh really well it was very short did you
just do it
she played movie midnight in the switch
she just did yeah but
that's not here pimping i want to talk
about you stop no
i want to talk about you no i just gave
him a vma actually
did you really yeah so cool yeah yeah
and that was cool because like we've
known each other for so long and so
for me to be able to give that to him
and just see how happy he was and i mean
he's worked so hard yeah and um and yeah
that was like a really cool moment but
it was really weird because it was
obviously we had to stand like 10 feet
apart yeah the whole thing is probably
so
me and him went riding like motorcycles
like five days before that
like like i was at his house like you
know and we were just like hey
the ruler now between them and then like
so when we saw each other like we gave
each other a hug and there was like
covered people that were coming up like
you guys need to be separate
he came into my dressing room after and
they came in and was like you need masks
this is like a dystopia
it's just it's a crazy time so you
mentioned that
this is the proudest work that you've
put out yeah how does
this album differ from the previous
music that you've done
well my old music was like extremely um
arrogant
and like just oh really part of a lot
i i feel like you know look i started
making music when i was like 18 or 19
and i was like an insecure
you know all 18 19 yeah and so i try to
like
cover it up with like you know these
like just
outrageous lyrics and like antics and
stuff like that which obviously
it worked right like it put me on tour
for like 10 years and like i made like a
career he's like
so bad but like put me on tour for no
but i hate it but the reason why i took
a hiatus is because i hated playing
those songs
okay it's like once i grew up and like
matured into the human being that i am
too did you write those songs
yeah yeah yeah yeah but i mean not a lot
of thought went in though you're looks
like i was like put out like
uh but it was it was cool because it
took me around the world and it like
literally like i would have nothing in
my life if it wasn't for music like
everything started from music yeah um
but when you're on tour for like nine
years and you're playing those songs
every night
and then you like mature and like become
you just get sick of hearing
i don't want to sing the song i don't
want to sing do you think people notice
like that change
100 percent i had a lot of people like
like hate me be like you changed
what was like the difference do you
think that people noticed were you just
like not trying as hard
no no one was like i close i used to
have like big two-inch
games you gauges yeah and i like chopped
my earlobes off so like if you
i don't know if you
well yeah and so i had to like chop my
earlobes off and reattach them to my
face does that hurt so
cool like like chopping them off or
actually stretching stretching them it
was so long i've had them since i was
like 16.
what made you want to get cages i've
just always
always wanted my whole body tattooed and
like i was like i've had like my septum
stretch to where i could fit like a
pencil through my nose
yeah took that out uh i haven't sleep
bites four times have both of them in
rows what's next
what's the snakebites right here oh
there i was like i thought i was
pinching my chin
see this is how much i know snake
white's on your chest
that's like vampire all right i got a
question so you're heavily tatted i can
somewhat see
do you have any uh dedicated
girlfriend's tattoo
yeah for the band no are you going to
that's bad luck oh wait
why why well i mean i feel like it's
like it's like when you get someone's
name tattoo on you and you break up yeah
but it's not a girl's name
it's it's your baby it's your band it's
yours
no no i'm just kidding because you
always end up having to like laser it
off and that hurts even more cover it up
or cover it up yeah i've never gotten
anyone's name tattooed on me what's your
favorite tattoo
oh that's so hard i like patience thank
you i have bart simpson
i have me as bart simpson tattooed on my
no you don't
simpsons is like my favorite show ever
oh it's great are you kidding me i have
a theory that the simpsons predict
everything and they're
and well everyone thinks that it's true
though it is it is true but they've also
done like five million episodes so it's
like you're gonna
you're gonna kind of like you have to
predict everything like of course the
pandemic was gonna like happen
eventually
yeah i mean but yeah i don't know it's
kind of creepy when you watch
like when someone posts a tick tock and
it's like it's like they predicted this
25 years ago it's like yeah
weird it's weird i want to get back to
the lyrics because you said that you're
constantly writing in your notes and
so do you write all the lyrics i write
all the lyrics i write all the melodies
nick writes all the music with our
producer he's kind of like a ghost third
band member
john feldman um he's a band called
goldfinger yes oh
yeah oh my god he's like the singer of
goldfinger and he's like a legendary
record producer like produced like all
my favorite albums growing up like the
used and like
taking back sunday so what has that been
like working with him have you been
learning a lot
so i've been friends with him for like
five years like five or six years and so
john's someone that i've always wanted
to make a record with and he's also just
like the coolest guy ever and like has
like a beautiful house in calabasas
where his studio is so like we like kind
of just like lived at his house for like
three months that's awesome
i just like didn't leave and he's the
only dude that drinks as much coffee as
me so like me and him just go like head
to head well how much coffee are we
talking about
at least 10 cups a day are you a coffee
addict i'm like addicted
yeah like i'm like at least ten cups
today i don't know how people can just
drink green tea i was gonna say if
you're a tea person i don't trust you
thank you yeah it sucks like that
doesn't do that's suspicious and plus
like if you wanna go hang out with
someone like hey you wanna get coffee
like i don't drink coffee it's like oh
what are we going to do
you want to go out to get green tea it's
like i don't like pizza what what does
that mean
what does that mean so through your
lyrics okay
what's the message that you're trying to
get across um
heartbreak um
vulnerability i feel like this album is
the most honest
and sincere i've ever been and it's like
me talking just about everything that i
wasn't able to in my old music this
music is probably your therapy it's like
very therapeutic yeah well i went
through a really traumatic time in
january like probably like one of the
worst experiences of my life
uh and just so happened to be in the
studio while that happened
yeah so it was like you know it was
cathartic it was like literally
pour everything that was going through
out into songs which is cool
that's really nice so with your song
eyes wide shut i sort of
you know analyze the lyrics a little bit
throw it at me uh
i don't know travis you talking about
someone in particular maybe a special
someone
oh 100 you have to
[Laughter]
about musical influences because your
music sounds very it's like pop punk or
what's hot how do you describe like your
genre i think it's like alternative and
like pop punk and like the music that i
grew up listening and i love like the
blink 182 fallout boy like cena you see
sophie and i
grew up with paramore good charlotte
like this yes that's like this
music is just so fun and i feel like i
haven't heard
something new like this in a really long
time so definitely when we were playing
it over or
she was playing a ton over and over
until jennifer yelled
um it was really exciting so what made
you call your mom by her first name
uh not all just a lot that's so funny
because you never do
and i always call my dad sly everyone's
like why do you say slime like because
it's not
i say to myself i say jen but i see mom
mostly but right now i'm just using
it some people get really weirded out
when we do that no i've just never i
don't think i've ever called my mom by
her first name
really i've never heard you do it either
this is doing it right now
i don't know okay i think it's cool it's
kind of like hey what's up
jeff homie she's like the homie jen's
the homie no but
did you oh did you want to go into that
type of genre or have you always made
music
well that was what i was doing first and
then you know when i was like 18 i got a
laptop and so i started recording myself
and just like kind of like
freestyling over like instrumentals and
just like being like oh hey like
whatever and throwing them up online and
then one of them just blew up and that's
like
all of this happened all of this is one
big accident everything's like fell into
place i feel like my whole life is like
one happy accident after the next
like everything i have in life is just
like just so happens
i think you put it out there though yeah
you know 100 percent i'm like a big
manifesto yeah and um you know like i
feel like i i think things
into fruition but um do you do something
specifically to manifest and then people
write things down like a hundred times
no
that's happened my whole life like even
like do you remember myspace
oh yeah of course so like i'd see like
someone cool on myspace and like
or like i'd be obsessed with a band like
i'd be like obsessed with a band
yeah and then like a year later i'd be
like best friends with them
wow so who who are these bands that you
were so obsessed with that
you sort of see yourself portraying well
like blink 182 is like one of my
favorite bands in the whole world yeah
and then like i and like okay so like
wiz khalifa was my favorite rapper
when i was 18. like before my music
popped off blink 182 was like i had
their posters on my wall i like fell
asleep every night listening to their
live album
and i'll never forget so like through my
musical journey i go on tour with wiz
we become really good friends i'm at his
house and then like also like i'm in the
studio with like travis barker and like
working on music
so our lives are so boring sistine what
are we doing right now we'll be in the
studio
i know but we can't sing we're totally
toned up but
there's an app for that i gotta start
doing it
all we do is talk too much but that's
that's why we have someone needs to take
one of your podcasts
and like clip funny things you say and
autotune it and make it into a song
okay you guys listening thank you
someone out there doing that and then
yes
anybody out of our four thousand
followers
you just need to say like some crazy
[ __ ] yeah clipped into a song
so i think it's um really cool your
music videos
they're very like 2000s vhs type shot
thank you um what does your creative
process look like when you're
you know coming up with a concept for a
video because i think it's so fun you
guys also
are wearing wigs and you're playing
different characters and you're just
having a lot of fun with it so
for example like we'll do california
yeah like what was your process for that
like what
uh well okay so we're nick and i are two
for four for music videos by the way so
we've shot four music videos we've only
released two
one of them no they're for the same
songs we scrapped them wait
are you serious swear to god so
california we shot a video at my house
because this was like height of the
pandemic oh yeah we did try to do a
whole green screen video with like a
director in like san francisco
and like it literally came out like
[ __ ] trash
no and i was like i was like okay we ca
i i haven't dropped a music video like
four years
yeah we are not putting this out and it
was unfortunate because it was like you
know
like the downfall of travis mills like
the horrible music video what happened
like we tried to like salvage it and it
just like wasn't you know sometimes you
just gotta know when to move on
yeah right luckily like you know i have
great relationships with with people and
so one of my friends
just who happens to be an amazing
director hit me up like yo dude i love
the new song
i was like hey funny you ask [ __ ] i
need i need a video
and so we just had a call and like you
know we like wrote a treatment together
and like we
we shot it in in i think a day and a
half and then
that that's a california video and then
i was like
we flew a director out and you know we
did this like
whole it was like a 10-hour shoot like
it was crazy
and we got the video back and i was like
once again like you can't it's just like
a running joke
at this point it's just like it takes us
two videos to get one right
but you i think you visually know what
you want yeah so when you don't get that
you want to keep working if you ever
need background dancers i was going to
say
you guys good dancers hello i can do the
finger worm okay
i can walk casually
in the background like a brisk walk like
just a bystander okay what do i do
i'm really good like sitting and reading
like she's getting oh i can roller skate
okay oh i can't i'm just saying i have
roller blades
no one in l.a does this hold on i think
rollerblading is way better than roller
skating sofia you're like a bambi on ice
when you roller skate
i however i'm a connoisseur well i can't
roller skate with the four
i could do the street too i could i do
the straight that's what i'm playing
wait i blade yeah
perhaps perhaps we make some roller
blade roller
yes we were just saying actually so
sistine and i have been trying so hard
to blow up on tick tock and we just got
one
no one thinks that blew up recently yeah
we were do you know new girl the show
yeah
dude yeah schmidt i actually saw your
guys's new girl thing where you're doing
this
yeah i actually did do that and i was
like [ __ ] i was like that's such a good
idea i
totally forgot i saw that but yeah do it
take care okay it's my favorite
character he is our favorite and so we
did it and all of a sudden we wake up
the next day it's like
five hundred thousand well i think it's
funny because we think we blew up with
like fifty thousand likes but compared
to what these other kids are getting
they're like
three million i'm like we made it yeah
yeah no it's a success for sure
are you gonna start doing tick tock with
with girlfriends because
i feel like that's i don't know we'll be
a tick-tock dancer
like i can't dance i'm six foot four i'm
just like you just have long limbs i'm
lanky
you're like the inflatable tube man
outside of except exactly
when we were filming the eyes watch out
video and like you know there's like
like director and we had like a model
like yeah like my like girlfriend or
whatever
it's like i'm walking backwards with
this like vhs camera and i'm like
wearing these what
these like [ __ ] doc martin like shoes
yeah brand new so they're super stiff
and i'm like walking back like in the
shot like pretending
and i [ __ ] my foot goes it like all this
space outside my foot goes into this
[ __ ] pothole
and my ankle just like and i just like
fell and we kept
i told him i was like yo you got to keep
that in the video did you oh see oh yeah
it did i said yeah
oh i didn't say that yeah yeah and then
you honestly look like you broke your
ankle oh yeah like it looked
chaos yeah she just like does the rest
of the video of you an embrace i'm
making a tick tock right now where i
just like fall and get back like it's
like
oh you know smart yeah i'm trying to do
that
that's so funny so i want to know a
little bit about your relationship with
nick
okay yeah i've done some research with
him that's really
that's a bromance in the first video for
eyes white shirt that didn't come out
so
yeah i don't know you can just like make
that viral try you know look we've only
been in a band for like
eight months so we're trying to like
speed up the time that like bands you
know usually bands are together for like
10 years
yeah so we're trying to like do all
these things that like make us closer as
band mates
you guys said i was gonna say
i knew he was getting i was like god i
knew it
kept going with it nick
nick does a whole ton of [ __ ] and we
call like pokemon cards so
that's all do you actually like pokemon
that's where the money's at no i've like
literally probably spent like 150
thousand dollars in the last like two
months oh no
we used to trade gold or she is a trade
goldfish for pokemon cards
i had a lot of crackers at the house so
i was like okay i'm going to give you
that and i want your pokemon cards we
used to yeah yeah i know
we were big tom boyce like video games
all we did do you still play
yeah yeah call of duty are you keen
assassin's creed 2 is my favorite
redemption i've never played red dead
i've beat world at war
three times damn so you guys are like
real deal gamers yeah but we don't have
like a twist or anything
okay i just launched my twitch and it's
been going awesome i feel like every
start
yes a gamer girl does anyone have a
twitch for like a wii tennis
for a week like that's what i want like
bowling like that's what i'm good at i
feel like you could blow it because it's
like so niche too
you know yeah right she's good at the
sports games i'm really good at like the
more combat i've got like like like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like
like
like
like
like
like
like
like like first person shooter yeah that's
like
that's all i like to play and scarlet we
all wait what's the other game that's
really good you're on a horse fortnite
no not fortunate right yeah
like when the zombies that come in and
then you have to defend the house
that's that's right we used to play like
at night and it was like pitch black and
then only the screen was almost like
when we'd stay up past 9 30 yeah crazy i
can't believe that that's so that's
so insane well you have the rock star
you know lifestyle yourself but i'm just
like
at home like on ebay like i'm not buying
pokemon cards yeah i was like
that's us with amazon and buying like
oil stickers or whatever
so um how are you guys adjusting
now that you're in covid so typically i
would assume that you would be on tour
you'd be selling shows all across the
country the world
so what are you doing to adjust right
now uh nothing
calling each other and being like what
when are we going to go on tour right
i would like to see a virtual tour so
nick has been i know i was so against it
i was so against it because i was like
the first time
people see us live i want it to be live
yeah i don't blame you yeah but with the
album coming out and we're like how are
we going to promote this
i think we're going to do that but we
haven't announced it yet so but people
had like some kind of small gatherings
and like that's a little bit i think
they've done like drive-ins and stuff
like that
you could do like a drive-in movie
theater type thing and everyone parks
their
trucks people like watching in their car
does everyone have a pickup truck
yeah they're standing on top of their
car oh man
yeah you're making out with nick people
are making out with their girlfriends
[Laughter]
you are like a working machine do you
like to work are you a person i'm a
worker
yeah and what's crazy with apple it's
like i have the apple logo tattoo on my
what the
show that's the camera okay but i've had
this since i was 18. like i
you know like i've just been a fan i
manifested it so that's what i'm saying
like i really i really do this
i'm gonna manifest uh i'm gonna put a
dog on my hand
i'm gonna manifest forbes 30 under 34.
maybe maybe just get like a little like
oh wait so you know
we were always talking about it because
i've always wanted a tattoo
okay but you get you both don't have any
no what are you scared of
i just i i'm such a fickle person that i
don't like to stick with one thing i
like my brain's always here here here
here like
you got a lot of real estate so if you
change your mind there's like the bottom
of my phone no sophia wants uh like
somewhat of a significant yeah an
initial like i would put my shoe size on
the bottom of my foot or something like
yeah right i'd be like 10 and a half if
you're wondering so
like a like a you know smiley faces or
the word foot
you know something like that like so
dumb no but right i don't know
because that's exactly what you want to
have so if he wants like a rose no i
don't think it's like something at least
that makes sense i have really dumb
tattoos as much as i have like
significant tattoos i have stupid ones
what's the dumbest one
i have gnarly tattooed on me twice
gnarly that's did you tattoo that or did
someone talk to you
okay so i tattooed gnarly above my knee
okay
and then i have gnarly tattooed on my
like across my whole stomach
the entire underneath my belly button
all the way down like where my belt is
down has the most interesting tattoos we
got bart we got gnarly i mean yeah
right he's like a pure serious dog party
downstairs
um so yeah so i have a fly that says eat
[ __ ] and die
on my wrist oh my god what what was yeah
what was the uh reason for that one
i don't know it was just me and my
friend were at dinner we're like let's
go get [ __ ] best friend tattoos and
he was like okay
but he bitched out at the last second no
he got it but he was too scared to get
the word [ __ ] tattooed on him so he got
like
a dollar sign an at sign a hashtag
he's like 10 yeah
what's going on exac dude it's like come
on tat this next tattoo
put our names no no oh my god no yes can
i tattoo it i have no names on me
what we're doing instead is you're not
gonna get the tattoo we're getting
girlfriend tattooed under our eyes or on
our left we have an instagram filter
with
it says girlfriend that's crazy you said
that yeah it says girls
yeah it has like california like they're
like face tattoos yeah
uh and it's like a face filter and so
yeah it says girlfriend's right under
the eye and it has california on the
other and like some like black freckles
so like girls
because girls like the girls love the
[ __ ] like i use it so much
i use it so much aren't the filters so
freaky today though
yes they're scary i was trying one this
morning
they make your eyes brighter lips bigger
tiny catfish
but really you i don't think you i don't
think do you think dude okay do you
think i look like my photos
absolutely actually okay i was not like
i why you don't think you look like your
pictures no i don't know
it's better when you look in person the
best compliment i always get or not
always kept but
i've ever gone with someone saying oh
you look better in person i was like
thank god if i was better like instagram
that would be the worst thing ever
everyone says that they're like oh my
god you're so much taller than i thought
and i'm like
dude you're just like [ __ ] do i look
do i need to like elongate myself in
photos yeah if you just start dancing
they'll see your height i can't do it
do we look the same in person yeah you
think so yeah
let me ask you this who do you think is
older
who do i think is old who looks older
yeah oh i'm so okay first of all i'm so
that's like the worst game for me
because people like hey how old am i
because i'm 31.
okay you don't you look 25 thanks well
that's a good thing i have gray hair
it's just okay was that is that real
like her hair yeah really
yeah but that's the look i thought it's
kind of cool thank you people are like
how did you dye your hair like that yeah
i started getting gray hair at 16 years
old i like
the gray i do yeah no i used to like
diet and [ __ ] and like four years ago i
was like
it's a look salt and pepper love it
thanks but i think
yeah i do think like i have a baby face
so like i'm like the worst at guessing
people's ages
you know so go um who's older yeah
or who looks older i don't know well
you're wearing a hat yeah
don't take the hat off it's a cool it's
a mastermind hat this is my dad's hair
it's phillip plams it's
my dad's yeah yeah i just stole it
uh i'm gonna go with you're older yeah
i feel like though everyone what's the
age gap i'm 24. i'm 22. actually that's
the first time someone's
got it correct yeah usually they always
say that i'm the baby and she's the
older one
yes i think it's a personality though
okay we're getting off track i really
want to ask
a few more questions a few more
questions um uh weird question if you
could describe
girlfriends the album in three words
what would it be
um fast sensual sad
sensual that was a weird thing
that's where your brain goes perfect
that's actually a great way to describe
it because i agree with that
what's your like it sucks don't listen
to it yeah actually you guys thanks
this is just for us to say that he sucks
and this
all sucks and don't listen to girls also
paid us to say that guys i paid to come
on here
um and yeah this album is awful honestly
yeah
i'm quitting the band he wanted us to
hype him up about his great hair nick
and i have been joking with everyone
being like yo
our first song got to a million streams
get it to two million or we're breaking
up before our first album comes out
we just made it let's go yo i've been
wanting to like troll
okay cause like look when you do [ __ ]
like you to do a bunch of press
obviously
yeah like it like it gets really
redundant yeah really old really quick
like especially like the tv show that i
do i have this mtv show yeah
ghosted so like a couple weeks ago i had
to do like 50 sec
it's called a satellite media tour yeah
[Music]
so you have to do like 50 [ __ ] live
news
channels like all back to back to back
to back and you started worse and you
start at 5 a.m so i had to do a day of
that like 50 live news channels and then
50 radio stations
so it was like two weeks i mean two days
of like [ __ ] hell
hell and it's like the same for like hey
you're [ __ ] on
klx 105. travis what's up with
ghosted you know and it's like [ __ ] with
ghosts that's the best
impersonation right don't know it is oh
my god yeah it's an
mtv wednesday nights you know so what
people getting ghosted what's that about
people getting ghosts you have to go
with the high prices have you ever
gotten kids that's exactly
and then they get off air and they're
like oh thanks man yeah yeah and they're
like dude hey
bro thank you so much welcome back
the amount of coffee i imagined you
consumed during this few days must have
been he's like twitching
yeah literally it was just it was it was
awful so uh we've been trying to like
find
fun fun things to to just [ __ ] with
people about you know because
obviously we just i hate like the
serious music conversation yeah yeah
it's like it's not like just like go
listen to the [ __ ] album just listen
i like i like like i feel like i'm way
more of like a you know
i want people to see my personality yeah
yeah but i feel like people are
you show your personality a lot on
instagram i think in a good way
i'm a shadow band right now why i dude i
don't know i think it was
like you're not really
no but yeah why did you get shadow band
what's the reason i don't know i was
going instagram live i was going on
instagram live a lot yeah
and i think someone like with like a big
following like wanted to go on my live
but i didn't know who they were
and they had a bunch of fans in there
that were like go [ __ ] live with her
go [ __ ] live and i'd like
no i'm not going live with this person i
don't know who they are yeah and
i think that they all those fans
reported my page
uh because like literally like
everything's just crazy on so wait when
you're shadow band what can't you do
well you can post and stuff but it's
like 25
of the people that follow me will see my
post opposed to like 100
oh that's so bad horrible timing
horrible timing you got to put an album
back
your apples come out 25 only get to see
it so we've been trying to fix it
and i don't know what to do so if
anyone's listening that works on
instagram
hit me up please because it's been
[ __ ] stressful
mark zuckerberg come on help him get out
shadow band at this point desperate yeah
i know
have him like look i if i didn't do
music and all this [ __ ] i wouldn't have
social media like i think it's kind of
yeah and people get way too wrapped up
in i was saying if we didn't have to be
on social media to like we would work
i would definitely delete it but i love
that if someone has a gun your head
they're like you better [ __ ] post
this
i know i was like okay okay the bikini
pick is good
okay take me back
no i i think it's really fun that you
you like to troll yourself and like you
don't take it too seriously and yeah um
you totally trolled yourself a lot today
which i love
yeah because it just you know makes life
we love software and i really
hope that's my brand that's literally my
brand yeah
because it's like yo people yeah if
someone's going to do it i like to do it
better than anything
you know oh you have insecurities here
it goes i'm tall
i can't dance dance i trip my voice
sucks
and i got bart on my leg
thank you so much for turning on me make
sure you guys go pre-save
girlfriends it comes out october 23rd
and definitely go check out their
already released songs california
eyes wide shot and if that is any
indication of what the album's going to
look like
it's going to be [ __ ] sick i'm so
excited for you go ahead and plug where
everyone can find
your album where they can pre-save uh
yeah it's just at girlfriends on
instagram which
easy plug yourself travis mills on
everything so yeah go follow me if you
don't already i'm sure you probably
already if you can't find him he's
shadow band
i'm shadow pants it's not my fault
they're trying to suppress me
uh yeah and write an instagram a lengthy
worded email to try to help me get my
heart back come on people
thank you so much yeah this is really
fun yeah bye
from all of us here at the show thanks
for staying on unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts spotify or
podcastone.com
follow your hosts at sophia stallone and
at sistine stallone
and be sure to follow the show at unwax
podcast
your producer is will sterling we'll see
you next week